today for our daily cancellation we turn
to the New Yorker and its recent write
up of two books that both quote consider
the ethics of procreation in the age of
man-made climate change now the title of
the article puts it in even more
dramatic terms uh quote the morality of
having kids in a burning drowning world
the question of how you can burn and
drown at the same time is never answered
instead what follows as a long
meditation of the ethical quandries of
choosing to have children in a world
that ised supposedly hurdling towards
ecological Armageddon the writer of the
article Jessica winter Begins by uh
recounting the time when she read a
newspaper article with a quote an
apocalyptic 50-year climate forecast and
resolved in that moment to never had any
kids of her own but she soon confesses
that she did end up having kids two of
them who are now nine and six and she
now seems to be plagued with doubt and
guilt because of her choice to have kids
a decision that she insists is uh
ethically
complex she tells us about the two uh
recent books revolving around this
question one of them is called the
quickening and it was written by a
journalist who spent some time with
Scientists in Antarctica and she reports
that the ice in Antarctica is melting
and we're all going to die soon or
something Reading from the article quote
Antarctica is Nature's egg timer poised
to tell us when we're fully cooked but
for Rush the author the continent
presented a different kind of threshold
a prologue to a personal trans formation
quote the year I go to Thwaites Glacier
in Antarctica is also the year that I
decided to try a to try to grow a human
being inside of my body she writes in
the quickening the central Paradox of
the quickening is the private urge
toward the creation of human life
coexisting with intimations of its in
imminent destruction quote should I have
a child their greenhouse gas emissions
will cause roughly 50 square meters of
sea ice to melt every year that they're
alive Rush writes just by existing they
will make the world a little less
livable for everyone themselves
included now the idea of making your own
life less livable by living in the first
place is of course totally
nonsensical but there isn't a lot of
time to reflect on that bit of nonsense
the article continues quote the author
draws an implicit parallel between
putting off having children and
humankind's delayed Reckoning with
climate change all at once she writes I
seem to have discovered myself sitting
almost at the limit of a thing wondering
how much longer I had to act she joses
the shattering of the Thwaites Glacier
in Antarctica and the bodily wreckage of
child birth now admittedly this is
something that you hear from women all
the time I can't tell you how many times
my wife during her four pregnancies said
to me you know man I feel just like the
THS Glacier in Antarctica this is
something women say all the time and we
go from there we get more Reflections on
the moral complications of having
children quote having a child is at once
the most intimate IR rational thing a
person can do prompted by Desir so deep
we hardly know where to look for their
Wellsprings in an unavoidably political
act according to Mian Chris who wrote in
the London review review of books in
2020 that essay is it okay to have a
child the title paraphrases a question
posed by Alexandro kesa Cortez the
congresswoman from New York in an
Instagram live stream is the load star
of a growing body of commentary that
debates the morality and ethics of
procreation in this Burning drowning
world
quote it seems increasingly clear Chris
continues that we are living in a time
of radical destabilization of life on
Earth which complicates the act of
bearing children in ways that Society
has yet to Grapple with activists have
attempted uh equally radical responses
to the moment the women of the
short-lived birth strike movement which
garnered attention at the end of the
2010s renounced having children on
account of the ecological emergency
although their message was often
misconstrued as a malthusian appeal for
population control now we're then told
about the plummeting birth rates Across
the Western World although the the
writer says that it's unclear all in all
precisely how much correlation exists
between Rising awareness of the
environmental crisis and steady declines
in the US birth rate which dropped for
six consecutive years through 2020
reaching a historic low this is a
question taken up by the other book The
Parenthood dilemma in which the author
quote portrays her own ambivalence
towards becoming a mother and the
ambivalence among Millennial and genzi
women more generally as the result of a
complex and extremely familiar interplay
of factors now one of the major factors
for the author Gina rushon is climate
anxiety although there are other
concerns that have led her to be quote
unquote child-free including the quote
persistent imbalance in division of
domestic and emotional labor in
heterosexual
Partnerships now by the end of the
article we're not given any final clear
verdict on whether we should have kids
or not uh I read all the way to the end
eagerly hoping that I would find out for
sure whether I should feel racked by
guilt guilt for having six kids and
perhaps single-handedly melting what
remains of the Thwaites Glacier whatever
that is instead we're left with
uncertainty and doubt and a lot of
ruminating about the complexities and
nuances of producing our own little
carbon dioxide machines it's a very
complicated question we're told very
difficult to discern who can say for
sure whether we should have kids or
whether we should stop having them and
voluntarily embrace the extinction of
our own species for most homeowners
window replacement isn't something that
they've done before and for many it
isn't something that they want to do but
rather something they have to do well if
you've put off replacing windows in your
home because it's too expensive I have
great news for you you can now get a
free inhome window consultation and a
free price quote from Renewal by
Anderson Renewal by Anderson signature
service is committed to giving you the
best customer service experience
possible through the perfect combination
of the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free inhome or virtual
consultation on durable quality uh
affordable uh windows or patio doors for
$0 zero payments and zero interest for a
year all you got to do is text Walsh to
200 300 for your free consultation to
save
$375 on every window and $750 on every
door these savings won't last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Walsh to
200 300 that's Walsh to 200 300 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted at text plan. us texting enrolls
for recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates may
apply reply stop topped out go to
windowappointment now.com for full offer
details well I've got a holiday gift
idea that's sure to make you the hero of
the season now we all know that the
holidays can be a bit hectic the
shopping cooking the never- ending list
of things to do but fear not because
I've discovered a gift that's not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
it's the gift of genus cell skincare
from now until Christmas genell's most
popular package has a special discount
just for my listeners at genucell.com
Walsh treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skin care in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness and yes even a
sagging jawline will disappear right
before your eyes with genus cell's most
popular collection genus cell promises
immediate effects you'll see results in
less than 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back you know
josell uh sent down a ton of products
for the entire office I can't even put
into work words how much better their
faces look because of genell everyone
now disgusts me a little bit less it's
like a Christmas early Christmas present
for me and you also deserve to look and
feel your best this holiday season so go
to genucell.com Walsh to get this
incredible holiday discount every order
today is instantly upgraded to free
express shipping that's genucell.com
walshay well maybe New Yorker writers
and feminist authors can't say for sure
aren't able to answer that question uh
but I can and the answer is that we
should have kids and we should have lots
of them and I don't think we need to
spend a lot of time here pointing out
how climate alarmists have been
prophesying the apocalypse for decades
and yet every forecasted doomsday has
failed to materialize what they're
claiming about the the the climate is
not fundamentally true whether global
temperatures are going up or staying the
same or going down it doesn't matter we
we are not heading towards the
apocalypse the world is not ending
anytime soon or I mean I guess I can't
say that for sure who knows when it's
going to end if it does it likely won't
be because you drive an SUV to work the
world will end when it ends and there
probably isn't anything you can do one
way or another about that fact what
should concern you more what you should
spend more time thinking about is that
your world you yourself will definitely
come to an end in a relatively short
amount of time the earth and the human
species will most likely still exist 100
years from now but you will not
and that's something you should consider
and as I've argued in the past I think
paradoxically that that people focus on
the climate apocalypse because they
don't want to think about their own
personal
death they're they're taking the anxiety
over their own mortality and kind of
funneling it into this broader concern
about the fate of the planet and then
they start advocating for policies and
laws and various political and economic
solutions that might prevent this
apocalypse and they do that because
there's no political solution to your
own mortality and that's what makes it
scary to think about but there are
political solutions to The Climate
apocalypse that they've invented in
their heads which is why they prefer to
think about that instead but this is all
somewhat beside the point because no
matter what's happening with the planet
we should still have kids either
way it's not a complicated question the
other option as an Al as an alternative
to procreation is
extinction if we did all make the
ethical choice to not have kids that
would be the end of all things it would
be the death of humanity
itself we will have allegedly saved the
planet by removing the reason that the
planet exists because what makes this
planet special makes it unique in our
entire solar system is that it is host
to Advanced rational self-aware
creatures who are capable of creating
civilization the planet has value
because we value it
we cannot preserve that value by getting
rid of the people who give it
value and more than that having kids is
what we're made to do you know it's
always funny to me that the people who
um are always trying to uh quote unquote
problematize procreation these are
almost always liberal atheists and yet
from an atheistic perspective we are
nothing but darwinian biological
machines and in that case literally our
sole purpose on on Earth is to
procreate that's the only reason we
exist if you are an atheist and you
declined having kids then you have
rejected the only reason that you exist
on the planet so your life is now quite
literally pointless by your own view of
things it is only on a theistic view of
life that you can find deeper purpose
beyond the propagation of the species
and yet on that view the correct view
still one of our deepest most Central
duties as people is to bring up the Next
Generation be fruitful and multiply is
the First Command given in the Bible for
a reason which means that either way no
matter how you slice it the idea that we
shouldn't have kids is not only wrong
but it is so absurd as to be basically
incoherent it's like saying that a tree
has a responsibility to not grow or a
bird is Duty bound to not
fly that's what they're made to
do and of course they should do what
they are made to do that's not even even
a question certainly it's not a useful
or worthwhile
question so yes go have kids add more
human life to the planet eventually
you'll die and your kids will die and
probably very long after that the planet
will die that's the way of human
existence which should not be seen as an
argument against human
existence which uh should be pretty
obvious and that's why really anyone
worried about the morality of having
kids in a burning drowning world is
today
canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there